public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nouveau visage de l'assemblée
nationale plus jeune plus féminin
également mais un président du palais
bourbon françois de rugy la législature
macro est donc lancée depuis quelques
heures et nous recevons l'un des
artisans clé de cette majorité jean paul
delevoye bonsoir j'ai eu un rôle actif à
importer bien sûr par le fanion
présidentielle puisque vous avez présidé
aux investitures de la république en
marche
merci d'entre avec d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec la
sp avec les échos et radio classique et
vous répondra ce soir aux questions que
viendront vous posez tour à tour jérémy
moreau jean francis pécresse et mickaël
à metz trois grandes questions donc ces
marcheurs et qui ont trouvé leur place
dans l'hémicycle alors de six loups
rebelles fronde impossible apparemment
puisqu'ils ont signé pour parler d'une
seule voix deuxième question comment la
nouvelle majorité va-t-elle débloquer la
france alors que la cour des comptes
s'apprête à dire la vérité douloureuse
plus douloureuse encore que prévu sur
les déficits enfin après l'assemblée s
objectif sénat pour la république en
marche mais d'abord une toute première
question d'actualité
[Musique]
puisque je le disais pas de révolution
féminine pour le perchoir contrairement
à ce qui avait été
1 10 ces dernières semaines on a parlé
d'une promesse d' emmanuel macron c'est
un homme qui a été élu président de
l'assemblée jean paul delevoye
l'écologiste tempéré françois de rugy
qui a beaucoup de qualités
vous allez nous les rappeler dans un
instant mais son seul défaut c'est
d'être un homme bon c'est pas un défaut
ce qui est important c'est la manière
dont le groupe en marche a choisi son
président ou la présidente
tout est ouvert tout est transparent et
eu un débat évidemment il y ait eu des
candidatures féminines
ensuite le groupe s'est exprimé à
proposer un seul candidat librement
librement librement mais absolument je
crois que si vous voulez de au sein du
séminaire que j'ai eu l'honneur d'animer
une team building du week-end dernier
j'ai pu me rendre compte de l'énergie de
l'appétence des parlementaires mais
surtout de leurs exigences on peut rien
leur imposer ils viennent de la société
civile certains ont exercé des
responsabilités au titre les entreprises
d'association est malade ces dernières
semaines on les entendait tout c'est
tout dire oh là là ce serait formidable
une femme au perchoir et à l'arrivée
c'est un homme oui mais ça fait partie
du débat il y une volonté de dire oui
moi j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait une
femme et puis ce débat a été portée il
s'est traduit par le choix d'un
président qui rassure d'un président
dont l'expérience permet de garantir
qu'il saura être à la bête à la hauteur
des différents enjeux on voit déjà
aujourd'hui à quel point il y à des
députés qui veulent notamment les
insoumis faire de la provocation
nous avons absolument besoin aujourd'hui
de trouver un débat apaisé aussi
ensemble avec son expérience un débat
respectueux des différences avec
quelqu'un qui a déjà à l'absolu c'est sa
nature de le dire donc il ya il a cette
qualité la france a du régime et de la
révolution la révolution qu'on nous
avait annoncé je reviens s'cusez moi une
femme enfin quatrième personnage de
l'état non c'est pas pour tout de suite
sauf qu'il y aura à la révolution c'est
ce que vous évoquez dans votre titre
notre groupe a considérablement fait
baisser la moyenne d'âge a
considérablement augmenté le taux
d'urbanisation et nous avons offert 50 %
des circonscriptions gagnables aux
femmes
donc nous avons joué notre part de façon
très importante d'ailleurs à la volonté
du président la rép
blick de pousser au maximum la parité il
y aura la parité dans les commissions
tous chercheront en permanence dans les
nominations en faire en sorte que cette
parité existe et vivent très bien et
pour le perchoir ce sera dans deux ans
et demi parce qu'alors c'est aussi un
fait nouveau nano sociable il va y avoir
un renouvellement désormais à mi mandat
ça c'est une nouveauté donc on peut
penser que la prochaine fois alors sera
la bonne pour une femme faut que vous
intégriez que pour le mouvement en
marche
aucun un poste aucun titre n'est perrin
sans avoir justifié et donc l'évaluation
est au coeur de notre démarche
évaluation des ministres évaluation est
remise en cause de toutes celles et ceux
qui exercent des responsabilités au sein
d'assemblées nationales et demain
lorsque le mouvement prendra vie
évaluation de nos référents de celles et
ceux qui exercent leurs responsabilités
d'accord alors vous avez parlé
effectivement des éclats de voix qu'on
aura sans doute du côté de la france
insoumise arrivée dans votre camp
certains parlent des aboyeurs de
l'assemblée concernant les extrêmes il
vous inquiète pas dû c'est vrai que la
réponse de vos élus ce sera quoi qu'il
arrive la bienveillance le calme
absolument hélas le bruit camoufle
quelquefois la faiblesse du fonds est
donc ce n'est pas parce que l'on créé
que l'on a forcément raison
je prends aussi nos concitoyens
attendent qu'on mette un terme à ce que
certains qualifiés de cire que des
questions au gouvernement dans lequel la
posture l'emporter le bruit l'emporté
sur la raison
nos concitoyens ont besoin de retrouver
fierté respect des parlementaires et
notre groupe sera extrêmement
respectueux de celles et ceux qui ne
font pas partie de notre groupe d
opposition et demi le ruban alors on
verra à l'usagé le suit tout de suite
avec jérémie moreau de l' agence
france-presse
l'épreuve de vérité votre question à
monsieur delevoye le voir championne
euros ces députés que vous avez choisi
soigneusement choisi durant des mois de
processus dresser nous un peu leurs
portraits leur profil
ce sera des députés godillots avec le
doigt sur la couture ou au contraire
est-ce qu'on pourra les entendre
exprimer leur voix leur conviction dans
l'hémicycle il est évident qu'au sein du
groupe cette diversité est une richesse
et nous avons très clairement dit au
cours de notre séminaire que nous avions
quitté la société de l'obéissance pour
être sûr des sociétés de la légion les
ministres ne doit pas demander aux
parlementaires d'obéir et doivent les
convaincre et la construction des
amendements la construction des textes
doit se faire en co construction et donc
probablement faudra-t-il réfléchir l'as
des procédures internes au groupe de
façon à éviter que les 340 50 députés
viennent avec chacun 10 amendements en
ce sens au congrès mais au contraire
qu'au sein du groupe il puisse y avoir
un débat sur des amendements moins
nombreux mais plus dense plus
stratégique plus essentiels par rapport
à l'esprit de la loi et donc leur
personnalité leur indépendance
la façon dont même ils ont été élus
quelquefois à la surprise générale fait
qu'hitler la leur trouvant la leur pour
beaucoup de personnes ont déjoué tous
les pronostics
parce qu'il y avait une vraie volonté de
la population de porter à l'assemblée
des hommes et des femmes capables de
porter un sérum de débats de ne pas
obéir mais d'être dans la reconstruction
d'un débat parlementaire qui va vous
servir le débat s'est pas l'écrasement
de l'autre parce qu'il n'a pas la même
étiquette de vous c'est l'enrichissement
par la construction or notre société
aujourd'hui à des positions
inconciliables dont j'espère qu'au sein
de notre mouvement et au sein de groupes
parlementaires on puisse se réapproprier
des débardeurs qui au sein des partis
politiques radicalise les positions et
le dra-10 l'action mais à la fin il ya
ce contrat avec la nation qu'ils ont
tous signé sur la survie mouvement sur
les grands jurys ses grands chantiers
sont très vaste qui les leur marge de
manoeuvre est ce qu'ils vont pas triste
finalement parler de la même voix tant
il faillit jo signé d'ailleurs on doit
parler de la même voix cet écrit noir
sur blanc
oui mais ce qui est important c'est que
lorsqu'il était candidat
une des questions c'est soutenez vous
adhérez vous au projet présidentiel
évidemment difficile d'imaginer que
quelqu'un se bat
pour être député en est en cours donc ce
qui nous fonde ce qui nous soude
c'est le projet présidentiel ensuite nos
cultures l'origine différente des
candidats fait que ce chemin pour
soutenir le projet peut-être diverses et
donc comment renforcer l'unicité du
groupe et la diversité des expressions
et donc ce qui n'est pas conciliable
c'est le soutien au gouvernement au
projet présidentiel
donc à un moment donné en exprimant les
lycéens sus il faut arriver à renforcer
le consensus ce qui n'est pas négociable
eu des déshérités ces cons ils soient
bayonnais et qu'il soit obligé d'obéir
sans s'exprimer
d'ailleurs le rend triste et la fronde
on a compris mais non non ne disent pas
du tout alors il retire pas du tout nous
sommes non alors je vais vous dire je
suis convaincue pour les avoir
rencontrés qui sont d'une d'une volonté
de construction ensemble de façon
extraordinaire aucun à l'esprit frondeur
par contre tout le monde à l'esprit de
pouvoir exprimer et être entendu c'est
ça qui est tout à fait nouveau c'est à
dire que dans un groupe quelqu'un pourra
s'exprimer même contre le ministre
évoquant tenter de le convaincre mais et
attendait le débat c'est ça la diversité
c'est permettre à chacun de dire par
rapport à ça est ce que tu es d'accord
ou pas et l'on voit bien que selon nos
cultures sur la loi travail entre la
liberté d'entreprendre la protection du
salarié
il y aura forcément au départ quand on
laissera la liberté de propos des
appréciations qui sont être différente
mais à partir de ces appréciations la co
construction permettra de renforcer une
loi plus juste plus profondément
appropriée par l'opinion c'est ça le
sujet et pas du tout la fronde mais au
contraire la construction ce qui est
intéressant voyez vous quand vous dites
cela c'est que vous êtes encore dans la
pensée d'hier l'unité c'est la
conformité et en ont mais pas du tout
mais au contraire c'est une unicité qui
va se renforcer sera nourrie par la
diversité qu'ils aient la force des
manuels macron c'est de voir fixer un
cap une vision un projet ce qui était
complètement reproché aux appareils
classiques
la deuxième chose c'est basé sur des
valeurs et ensuite avec un calendrier
très clair dans les six premiers mois
la loi sur le terrorisme la loi sur la
transparence moral et ensuite la loi sur
le travail et ils ont tous intégré cette
volonté de
deux séquences et les lois pour pouvoir
transformer le pays et donc qu'ils sont
ils sont pas du tout brisé ils sont au
contraire en adhésion
c'est ça qui est intéressant cette
plateforme informatique on les
alimentent on est bien sur le langage
bien sûr bien sûr ils sont encore deux
lacs et quand même ils ne sont pas
cornaquer ils sont accompagnés
c'est différent tous les celles et ceux
qui sont venus de partis dits de partis
différents qui nous ont rejoints qui
avait l'étiquette en marche ont été
absolument époustouflé par la puissance
que nous mettions à leur disposition
accompagnement pour les inscriptions à
la préfecture argumentaire éléments de
langage réponses à des questions qu'il
se posait et c'est cela la nouveauté
c'est que nous sommes une famille
d'hommes et de femmes venant d'horizons
différents dans lequel nous allons
échanger en permanence confrontés nos
opinions confronter nos arguments pour
faire en sorte que sur le terrain nous
puissions convaincre est-ce qu'à la fin
finalement ce patchwork idéologique ça
va pas se mêler les ferments de la
fronde s'est pas là qu'on va voir les
lignes de fracture se dessiner au sein
d'un groupe qui est énorme et finalement
assez hétérogène et moi j'ai présidé
pendant 10 12 ans ou dix ans
l'association des maires de france mon
bureau était composé de 50 % de gens de
gauche 50 % de gironde ou ratent 99% des
décisions ont été prises à l'unanimité
quand on travaille sur des causes skis
et a totalement intéressant c'est au
contraire quelle chanson à savoir sur la
loi travail des cultures différentes qui
vont pour mettre pour certains de
vouloir libérer d'entreprise pour
d'autres au contraire par leur culture
de vouloir protéger le salarié et le
trouver le juste équilibre
c'est toute la force des manuels macron
de faire en sorte de sortir de cette
société qui était radicalisé par les
postures politiciennes et qui
neutralisait l'action qui au contraire
à partir de ces positions puisse essayer
de trouver un chemin du consensus et d'
équilibre entre l'intérêt des
entrepreneurs et la protection des
filles à un mot qui revient beaucoup
j'ai vu un dans la déclaration politique
du groupe c
progressiste ça c'est ainsi martelé
quasiment à chaque fois à l'office et
l'equilibre voilà et alors on avait
appris aujourd'hui que manuel valls
finalement aller siéger comme député
apparenté au groupe e la république en
main ça c'est alors il sait le supplétif
de dernière minute n'ont cessé lorsque
manuel valls que j'avais rencontrés pour
l'investiture dans les critères ils
n'étaient pas recevables et le président
la république a souhaité faire un geste
nous avions été frappé par sa sincérité
je quitte le parti socialiste je
soutiens le projet présidentiel et au
nom de cette sincérité nous avions
décidé de ne pas mettre de candidat
contre lui
et donc c'est une démarche logique et
cohérente avec toutes les positions
qu'emmanuel base au prix mais nous
respecterons et manuel valls par son
parcours parle par le fait qu'il fut
ancien premier ministre et c'est pas du
tout un supplétif c'est au contraire
nous sommes un espace politique dans
quel chacun peut apporter sa
contribution à soutenir un projet qui ne
peut que s'enrichir de cette de cet
apport vous vous disiez le président a
décidé de faire un geste concernant le
manuel valls il décide beaucoup quand
même le président il a la main aussi sur
sur certaines investiture on a vu aussi
le message qui l'envoyaient en
choisissant richard ferrand qui a été
choisie à l'elysée est ce que l'élection
de richard ferrand finalement ce n'était
pas un point celui là qu'on a même parlé
d'élections soviétique du côté du parti
socialiste
alors oui mais moi j'ai participé à
cette élection et je peux vous dire que
nous avons suggéré plusieurs
candidatures mais chacun s'était exprimé
en dix ans mais nous mesurons bien là la
dimension du poste dirigé 350 députés ça
n'est pas donné à tout le monde
il faut avoir une autorité naturelle il
faut avoir un crédit il faut avoir une
certaine expérience et beaucoup ont dit
mais non nous ne souhaitons pas être
candidat parce que nous estimons qu'à
cette dimension-là richard ferrand à la
dimension de costumes et nous avions
décidé de voter à main levée ce qu'il ya
classique il ya eu deux abstentions
d'ailleurs en disant je regrette qu'ils
aient par un autre candidat mais tout
simplement personne de contester la
dimension de rigueur et du batteur du
groupe
les convocations devant la police la pj
de rennes vous inquiète concernant
richard ferrand non parce que dans ceux
ci voulaient là chacun vit sa vie
les principes restent les mêmes c'est à
dire que si vraiment il y à une mise en
examen là il y aura à réexaminer la
position de richard ferrand comme
d'autres savez la force d'un groupe la
force d'un mouvement c'est 2-2
d'affirmer la force des principes les
principes ne se discute pas et les
principes s'appliquent à l'échelon le
plus élevé ou simples militants
mais là on s'est dit qu'il y avait une
différence justement entre 2 7 et 2
ministres et le statut du président il a
lui-même dit qu'il ne mettrait pas en
avant son immunité parlementaire
donc les choses sont claires merci
beaucoup jérémy puisque la suite de
l'épreuve de vérité tout de suite c'est
avec jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique
[Musique]
bonsoir jean francis st michel bonsoir
jean paul delevoye alors la cour d'école
selon des informations de presse
s'apprête à rendre public son audit des
finances publiques de la france est
selon cet audit il y aurait un dérapage
de 9 milliards d'euros sur l'année 2010
est qu'ils auraient été cachés au fond
mais ma question est simple est-ce que
vous réforme est ce que les réformes des
manuels mâcon ne sont pas compromises
par l'ardoisé laissée par françois
hollande d'abord opération vérité je
crois que ce qu'il est important je me
souviens des quinquennat précédent on
avait du mal à faire le bilan est de
même du mal à assumer le bilan
nous ne cherchons pas à condamner l
prédécesseur etc
cherchons simplement à nous dire à
partir du moment où on a un programme
quinquennal avec une trajectoire qui
sera demandé à chaque ministre avec une
responsabilité de chaque ministre de
suivre cette trajectoire c'est tout le
crédit de la france à l'échelon européen
et à l'échelon international
il est important qu'on fasse le point et
moi je salue le travail de la cour des
comptes qui va très clairement affiché
la réalité des chiffres et qui fait
qu'effectivement nous risquons de passer
au delà 3 3 2% et 3 3% et train train du
déficit
ça veut donc dire qu'il y aura à partir
de ce constat avoir un débat sur le
moyen d'abord de ramener en dessous de 3
% dès cette année si cela est possible
sur quels sont les efforts à consentir
et ensuite comment rétablir une
trajectoire à partir de cette situation
que nous pressentions mais dont nous
avions besoin de savoir exactement
quelle était la clarté il ne vous a pas
échappé que sur 7 sp quinquennal certes
cette situation est préoccupante à court
terme
par contre on voit un certain nombre de
choses qui à moyen terme semble se
dégager une relance de la croissance
européenne des perspectives de reprise
d'entreprise et d'investissement un
regard international positif sur la
france et si le programme législatives
abouti dans les délais les plus brefs
des signaux extrêmement forts sur une
mobilisation pour accélérer cette
perspective avec des perspectives donc à
plus moyen terme mais à court terme il
va falloir prendre des mesures
déficit c'est ce que disait hier le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire en
l'écoutent
nous ferons avec gérald darmanin au
premier ministre au président de la
république un certain nombre de
propositions qui concerneront tous les
secteurs de dépenses publiques ont pas
passé le rabot sur un ministère ou sur
un autre
faut que l'état les collectivités
locales les dépenses sociales
chacun fasse un effort pour qu'au bout
du compte nous retrouvions notre liberté
et nous respectons nos engagements
européens
si nous ne faisons rien d'ici la fin de
l'année 2017
eh bien nous ne tiendrons pas nos
engagements européens nos engagements
européens c'est ce que disaient aussi le
commissaire européen
pierre moscovici sur radio classique
hier il n'est pas question que la france
repasse ne repasse pas saoul les 3%
comme elle s'y est engagée
donc il ya un objectif de court terme
qui paraît quand même très dur à
atteindre sans renoncer peut-être à
certaines baisses d'impôts tous les
débats sur sur la table le ministre l'a
dit il fera des propositions au premier
ministre que pouvoir très clairement
quelles sont les mesures à prendre
plutôt que d'avoir ce que souvent il été
décidé un rabot uniforme
nous avons besoin à partir de cette
lecture très précis de la situation de
la france de voir effectivement si tout
est possible si tout doit être reportée
en matière de baisses d'impôts en tout
cas des économies importantes en matière
de dépenses publiques
il y aura aussi une visibilité et l'on
voit bien sur le régime des retraites
loi bien par port sur l'unedic
ce qui est important avec le président
de la république ce nouveau gouvernement
c'est que l'on a une visibilité sur cinq
ans et a fermé les vannes audi et ce
sans être reporté je pense alors mais je
n'étais je n'en sais rien mais sur la
cohabitation la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation ou de je pense que à partir
de ce constat le ministre de l'économie
fera des propositions premier ministre
le premier ministre garde à ce qu'il est
possible de faire ce qu'il est difficile
de faire ce qu'il est souhaitable de
faire et les parlementaires auront si ce
type de débat à partir de ce moment là
il ne faut s'interdire rien sauf une
seule obligation revenir en dessous des
3% est revenu une trajectoire positive
il ya des engagements de campagne qui
ont été pris et vous n'y auriez pas
quand même que
y avait un certain nombre de dépenses
budgétaires qui n'était pas à financer
qui étaient cachées qui était ce qui
était bon sous le tapis une certaine
manière tout le monde a parlé de ça
pendant des mois et des mois
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à nous dire
maintenant que vous découvrez une de
situation qu'on connaissait à peu près
tous quand même lorsqu est clair c'est
que lorsque le président le candidat
emmanuel macron avait son programme avec
jean pisani-ferry il a été salué par la
totalité des économistes 1 sur la
qualité de ses prévisions et de il s'est
basé sur les chiffres qui étaient à
notre disposition il en voit bien que si
l'on commence à faire des campagnes sur
peut-être que des hypothèses sont moins
bonnes son meilleur etc
on a vu tourner tout vu on l'a vu aussi
des candidats qui se basait sur les
corps sur des scénarios extrêmes anti
réaliste et donc aujourd'hui notre
situation est une citation de franchise
et de transparence avec l'opinion de
retour au réel
parlons de retour au réel celui bon cv
la confiance de nos concitoyens
vis-à-vis des politiques c'est certes
l'exemplarité c'est certes la
transparence mais c'est aussi la vérité
et je crois qu'il ne faut rien cacher
rien cacher sur la réalité des chiffres
et sur les efforts à faire pour revenir
et ensuite tu auras une pédagogie à
expliquer pourquoi ces efforts sont
nécessaires pour redonner une dynamique
européenne qui garantira un meilleur
futur pour nos concitoyens
vous allez remettre un peu de fillon ou
font dans le programme mâcon c'est ça ce
que vous êtes en train de me dire je
vous rappelle que monsieur fillon
commencé à perdre parce que personne ne
croyait à la capacité de pouvoir mettre
en oeuvre son programme
rappelez-vous sur la suppression des
fonctionnaires sur la réduction des
déficits etc et donc il ne faut pas
tomber dans ce genre de formules
classique et pas d'un côté les méchants
et les bons et aujourd'hui des chiffres
et comme le disait tony blair de bonnes
ou de mauvaises politiques
aujourd'hui la france a la capacité de
pouvoir tirer profit des feux verts qui
sont en train de s'ouvrir à l'échelon
européen et y compris les champs de la
france si nous ne prenons pas les
mesures de rectification par rapport à
la situation plus négatif que nous
imaginions bien évidemment nous allons
rater cette opportunité de la croissance
demain matin le gouvernement présente le
projet de loi kill habilitera affaire
par ordonnance sa réforme du code du
travail est ce que cette réforme elle va
suffisamment loin à votre goût il ya une
demi réformes sur le contrat de travail
et les seuils sociaux que les
entrepreneurs souhaitent voir relevée ne
sont pas dans cette dans ce projet de
réforme est ce que ça va assez loin
c'est la caractéristique du gouvernement
c'est de trouver toujours entre le
souhaitable et le possible un chemin
d'équilibré
on n'est plus dans l'ère des postures où
on faisait croire c'était le cas de
monsieur fillon veut c'est moi le plus
fort le plus costaud jeu personne n'y
croyait c'était le cas de monsieur hamon
qui faisait rêver tout le monde
aujourd'hui entre ce qui est souhaitable
par les uns et ce qui est interdit par
les autres il faut trouver un juste
mesure et c'est exactement ce qui a été
fait sur les sf ce qui va être fait sur
la loi travail ce qui va être fait
demain sur sur les systèmes de retraite
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui de faire
prendre conscience à nos concitoyens
qu'il ne s'agit pas de les punir pour
les erreurs du passé qu'ils n'ont pas
commises mais qu'ils subissent et
d'essayer ensemble de construire quelque
chose de possible de sueur et âme pour
chacun merci merci jean francis hallé
dernière partie de l'épreuve de vérité
monsieur de le voir monsieur kraus avec
mes 15 ms d'un public sénat qui arrive
[Musique]
enfin mickaël bon sens michel ils vont
s'empresser de le voir alors après
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous
êtes parti pour prendre le sénat
oui la présidente alors tendu oui oui
oui
objectif sénat g bâle entendu votre
question c'est de préparer les élections
sénatoriales la réponse est oui et donc
la présidente madame catherine barbaroux
m'a confié la présidence de la
commission nationale d'investitures nous
allons que nous avons déjà commencé un
peu de travaux nous allons de démarrer
jeudi
notre première réunion de façon à
pouvoir département par département
être présent partout partout pareil il y
aura des listes république en marche
partout nous aurons une position du
mouvement partout et donc il y à des
débats aujourd'hui très clairement posé
des positions mais quand ça veut dire ça
veut dire que des candidats estampillés
en marche partout ou éventuellement des
listes sur lequel il y aura le label
majorité présidentielle avec la
possibilité d'une inscription dans
d'autres groupes en tout cas c'est un
débat que nous avons actuellement
puisque l'on voit bien que la réalité du
sénat est très différente de celle de
l'assemblée nationale et qu'un certain
nombre de personnes sont très attachés à
pouvoir soutenir la politique du
président de la république et en même
temps de pouvoir rester dans leur groupe
d'appartements c'est l'un des critères
qui a poussé aujourd'hui françois
patriat sénateur de côte-d'or a créé ce
groupe un groupe autonome il le veut qui
soutient véritablement à 100% le chef de
l'état car du côté du ps comme de l air
le dit il le dit les options sont trop
nombreuses entre l'abstention entre
opposition au soutien plus ou moins
bienveillants on écoute monsieur patriat
le formidable printemps démocratique qui
a eu lieu au cours de ces dernières
semaines ne peut pas rester à l'apport
du sénat pour un souci premier de
clarification vous avez compris que
certains groupes aujourd'hui
réfléchissent entre eux pour savoir
quelle sera leur ligne et nous ne
pouvons pas nous qui sommes adhérents
dans marge qu'ils sont
un instance d'adhérer en marche exister
dans un groupe où l'ambiguïté survivrait
qu'est ce que vous dites à françois
patriat par exemple quand on regarde la
composition du groupe c'est 70% venues
du parti socialiste est ce que quelque
part ça vous gêne non non parce que ce
qu'il faut intégrer dans le cas macron
qui perturbe toutes les analyses
politiques classiques c'est qu'il faut
jamais l'analyse et de façon statique il
faudra nager deux factions dynamique et
avec une temporalité différente
qu'est ce que ça veut dire côté qu'il
engageait la campagne présidentielle il
avait déjà un regard sur les listes et
idées que nous étions sur les
législatives nous a eu un regard sur les
sénatoriales sur les européennes et sur
les municipales et que ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui pour la maturité de la
division du parti socialiste va devenir
vrai demain pour les républicains juste
après les législatives et on le voit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui toutes les débats
qu'il y a dans les groupes dits
classiques sur le vote de confiance 25
pour l'astronomie
ce groupe est amené à s'élargir vous
espérez vous vous demandez par exemple
aux centristes de venir vous rejoins en
tout cas pour l'instant
non mais je vous dire que il y avait
besoin d'avoir un groupe qui était très
clair dans sa tête et dans sa position
pour dire nous sommes en marche
nous avons subi un projet présidentiel
et ça ne se discute pas et puis autour
de cela ce qui est vrai l'assemblée
nationale aussi nous aurons toute une
série d'hommes et de femmes qui quelles
que soient leurs appartenances estiment
qu'ils ont besoin d'apporter leur
soutien à la majorité présidentielle et
beaucoup desire nous ne voterons pas
contre la motion de confiance de posés
par le gouvernement et donc petit à
petit la clarification de l'offre
politique à laquelle nous amène emmanuel
macron qui consiste à revenir non pas
sur des clarifications pour le pouvoir
bien que la réplication sur les idées
fait que sur les quelques années qui
viennent et sur le quinquennat nous
aurons à ce nous assisterons à des
évolutions du mouvement qui grandira
amenée à grandir justement ce mouvement
est ce que vous êtes prêts aujourd'hui
où vous piètre président de la
commission d'investiture à vous dire
pourquoi pas un candidat pour la
présidence du sénat on parle beaucoup du
sénateur centriste michel mercier qui
visiblement seraient tentés alors nous
nous sommes pour l'instant préoccupé par
analyser
chaque département le choix de nos
candidats et le choix de nos listes dans
les candidats les départements ain
proportionnelle il appartiendra au vu
des résultats de tirer les analyses de
dépôt fédération politique absolument en
son temps y est favorable
il sut de vauxrot et pourquoi pas bien
sûr mais ça fait partie des hypothèses
il faudrait il faut écarter aucune
hypothèse vous savez pour le parti
est-ce que vous même vous seriez
candidat à la présidence de ce parti et
il faut parle de la république en marche
alors la question ne se pose pas moi je
suis avec le président la république
porteurs de mission demandée par madame
barbaroux j'ai rempli ma mission avec
les bandes de la commission pour les
législatives on m'a demandé d'exercer
cette même responsabilité pour les
sénatoriales moi je me contente de me de
mes missions
voilà donc ce sera quoi la direction une
direction je n'en sais rien qu'au
logique nous mêmes
je ne sais pas non à la barbare ou et
réclamante indiqué qu' elle mettait un
terme le 8 juillet ces fonds suite
aucune des crocos les jeunes c'est
imaginable il tout et je sais que les
gens ses proches quand même et vous
devez avoir une idée non je sais qu'il
ya une étude des statuts qui a été mise
en place et y ait des consultations
parlementaires il est l'insulté sur des
des référents on garde cet esprit de
participation où chacun se sont
concernés par les critiques les
formulations les propositions à faire
pour l'analyse des statuts est ce ce
parti politique naîtra le 8 juillet
alors je n'en sais pas plus que vous et
en tout cas moi à titre personnel pas du
tout vous avez vu les 577 candidats est
bien plus ou législative ou voyez
maintenant les candidats aux
sénatoriales
vous avez répété pendant la campagne
comme certains qui est marre de voir les
parlementaires fatigué est ce que vous
les croisez encore beaucoup ce que je
voulais dire c'est que ma préoccupation
c'est de lutter contre la fatigue par le
vendeur quand je voyais les
parlementaires qui à l'issue de leur
premier mandat estimé qu'ils étaient
fatigués d'être et qu'il n'allait pas se
représenter pour moi c'est quelque chose
de préoccupant
il faut que le parlementaire retrouve le
plaisir d'être parlementaire
puis je sentais aussi la fatigue des
électeurs qui ne voulait même plus aller
voter sur ces deux fatigue nous avons
besoin d'engager un vrai combat du
plaisir du parlementaire et les plaisirs
du citoyens à aller voter
merci beaucoup monsieur merci à vous
merci bonsoir à tous à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]